so that people who are viewing this
remotely can can watch it
that's right you all guys gotta watch
yourselves
ah good afternoon everybody so
you've got uh got 10 minutes uh jack and
then uh
councillors will ask any questions that
they want at that point in time
so the floor's yours very good
uh first question you had was a
separation of waste and storm water
although it doesn't really apply to me
because we're up on a rural block and we
have a septic tank
and the rest of the stuff goes into
drinking water tank
we would if it came to the crunch we'd
prefer to pay our own way
and that will depend on the council
making its mind up
on a decision that they've left and a
deferral
to allow the property to be changed to a
full rural
place or stay in the rural
urban situation we've got now and that
was because we accessed the highway from
from state highway one
and as i say is until you guys make your
mind up what we're going to be
question two option three answer there
is yes
to the library roof amazes me that we
have no local builders capable of
repairing the roof
uh i can't say much more than that
because obviously it would have been
done by now you've had the money set
aside to
to do it can it not be shifted in a
broken down state in a manner that will
allow it to be reconstituted on another
site
be a fancy looking wool shed
question three option four
special rural fund yep
go and do it the answer is yes to that
one
i've got this last one as other comments
and it's in relation to the attachment
that i sent to you guys did you want to
question me on anything up to now or do
i just carry on
no just carry on yeah it frustrates me
that this whole info
sheet is about reducing debt yet at the
same time we're talking about expensive
projects that are in the works or
underway
i don't know who came up with the idea
of or who does some preliminary in
investigations into how you're going to
attack these big projects
but they're out of phase with what the
district needs or can afford two
projects that are looming on the horizon
are the sewage ponds and the escort
water treatment plant
in line with the bridge you hope to get
there's nobody on the council have the
ability to think outside the square
the sewage ponds during the recent
floods
the flow rate of the material river
peaked at 2400 cumex
the ponds are approximately three
hundred meters wide by eight hundred
meters long by about a
meter deep so their contents are approp
approximately two hundred and forty
000 cubic meters therefore if the
flooded
breached this ponds it would have
flushed them
in 100 seconds one minute and 40 seconds
of that flood if had gone over the wall
would have cleaned it out
or done a good job of starting it
i can thank councillor cliff bulger
who's i hoped would be here today for
inviting that
out of the square thought because we
were having a cup of coffee up the north
door dairy
and uh i asked him what he was going to
do
if it ever happened and he just stood
there and put his arms out and he said
problem solved
i didn't think it was very clever it was
going to be a bigger problem wouldn't it
hmm you've seen him floating past your
driveway tracy i'll quote him on that at
some point
finally i attached a fairly wordy
document here
and the people that need to read it are
the ones on the council
the three million dollars plus that
could be saved
and used to reduce the debt
forget that silly looking bridge and
just build the pipeline
any questions yet
if you can just go right through and
then counselors will ask any questions
they have
might need mahafra to get through this
hi folks i thought i should bring you up
to speed with a recent adventure
through the resource consent process
which is related to the water pipes from
the jacobstown wells to the
score water treatment plant what what
you can do jack though sorry i should
have said it before is
take it as read that counsellors have
read the submissions
yeah right through so you don't unless
you want it you're more than welcome to
read through
but you don't have to i'll give it a go
yeah
a bit simple to start with because the
whole project exploded out into a
multi-headed beast with multiple
facebook posts
and resulting in the mirror placing a
two-page
q and a session with it with a
presumably
ratepayer funded center spread near
matera
ensign i've put the
email or the internet address for the
two-page
insight thing there that might have been
the end of it but unfortunately or
perhaps fortunately
there were some large errors in this
article position of potential bridge
sites
huge distance errors etc some of these
distance errors interested me
and i set about checking them simply
could not make them fit in the space
that they were said to
it was not until sometime later while
checking the government tenders page
that a request for interested parties
for part of the pipeline construction
described how a size upgrade for a
section of the existing pipeline was
required in maitland street
this explained the missing section of
pipeline distance and increased the
pipeline distance plus cost
there is a map that was what the inter
internet
referral was to of the intended
pipelines
routes in that two-page epistle and the
first thing that jumped off the page is
the pipeline starting in the jacobstown
wells area and travelling all the way
down the flood plain to a point
just across the river from the northern
tip of river terrace
over the river by an imaginary bridge
and then back up the east flood plain
adjacent to a critical point in the
flood bank between oxford and church
streets
and upwards upward street to the
crossroads at warwick
maitland street then right turn onto
maitland street and up to the
school water treatment plant quite a
hefty distance
when you think about it especially when
you have to pump the water on the way
out
next thing most noticed is why the heat
do all that work
when you could simply put a trench in
the riverbed run the pipes through a
structure that lies in the trench
concrete it over so so nothing can
impede the flow or entrap debris
during flood conditions to keep the folk
at the environment and south
south and happy that pipeline is
pipeline is virtually straight by
comparison
wouldn't that be the sensible option the
last two plus months have seen the river
drop to a very low
level which would have made the pipeline
in a trench construction very simple
so now we come to the infamous bridge
the council have chosen
to place this bridge at the chosen site
requires the pipeline to be nearly twice
the length of that required for just
maitland street
another little secret popped out of the
hearings that now
calculated that the pipeline cost will
be 871 dollars per meter
that's quite a jump from the 500 plus
that per meter that was initially
proposed
to dig a ditch regardless
there jack but uh the bell is uh eight
minutes so
another two minutes to go right
i'll skip a lot of that because as you
said you guys have got it
and when you recalculate out
the pipeline costs based on mats
numbers and you leave out
the five million dollar bridge that
the boys from three waters kept putting
in there for a bridge
at that point on the maitland street
that means that that option came out at
one million
three hundred and thirty two thousand
six hundred and thirty dollars
whereas your preferred option
is gonna come out at six million two
hundred and twenty five
thousand nine hundred dollars
by the time you get the actual
pipeline concreted in there you're still
gonna have
three million dollars over wouldn't that
three million dollars do a better job
and all the other debt the council's got
i hope you're taking it on board
that's about it i've got other numbers
here that back it all up but
okay um look thank you jack and i'm
i guess um what you've said is
is no surprise to counsel uh we've been
well aware of
the thoughts that you have over a period
of time so
this is not the the first time we've
seen this um
so it's open for councillors who have
any questions at all
of jack at
the process this afternoon jack and i'm
sorry to keep jumping back i've
talked about it at the start of the
meeting but you don't have the cure here
so the council are just here to answer
questions
make sure they understand everything
that you're uh
putting forward to the council today so
that
uh when we get to the deliberative
meeting which is next week
then we can make an informed decision um
with all the facts
in in line so today's not about a debate
debate today is about seeking as much
clarity of information from submitters
that we possibly can
so as with that in mind is there any
questions counselors might have
does not okay um look i just want to say
thank you jack for the time
and the effort uh that you've put into
both being here
and submitting a submission that has
a lot to ponder on as as we go through
the next week or ten days
so so thank you very much
i should have pointed out there is one
thing in there and you guys will read it
too
i'm not directly affected by this
i live up on top of the hill and escort
at best all i would see is the
bridge pole sticking out of the ground
that's about it okay great
thank you right uh
i think we've just about exhausted
all the submitters that are in the room
am i right in saying that
is there anybody here that um is
scheduled to make a submission and has
not heard
been heard yet no so look we might just
recess until uh the two
that have yet to come uh chris smith and
adam newton
uh either appear at the um appointed
time
or um or not as the case may be
between now and then joe stringer was
down to present but he has since said
that he's not going to be
so in the short time we've got we'll
just take a
short recess thank you councils
knife
so